hi everyone
i'm sad omar and the director of the
yale institute for global health for
those of you who don't know me
i'm very delighted to welcome you to
this virtual discussion focused on
updating
folks on the recent outbreak
of monkeybox obviously the phenomenon is
recent
and these sets of outbreaks
are
attracting attention
in countries outside where it has been
endemic the
you know monkey box has been
an issue
um and has been causing outbreaks for a
while uh in several countries
unfortunately uh these things attract
attention uh when it spreads more widely
especially
where there are uh sort of western media
markets uh so so keeping that in mind
um so so this which reminds me that when
you go to the so-called source of the
nile
uh in uganda there's a plaque uh
there's a flag that says that it was
discovered by this and this british
explorer and there's a plaque next to it
that says well actually we knew where it
was all along uh this guy showed up and
introduced it to the western world so
keeping that in mind in terms of monkey
parks
as well i'm very excited to have three
distinguished
guests
joining us today
all of whom are experts in infectious
diseases and global health related
topics
before our
questions
before moving to questions and
discussions
i will introduce
each of our panelists uh the first one
is dr andrew moyne
she's a professor and the gordon levin
endowed chair in infectious diseases and
public health
at the ucla fielding school of public
health
uh dr rewind is an internationally
recognized expert on emerging infections
global health and surveillance systems
and vaccination she has been working on
on monkey packs uh before it was cool at
least you know in in certain circles i i
i know that it was cool for her all
along she did her k award on that uh and
uh you know
has been
working on this
infection for a while
her work has focused on the emergence of
infectious disease and populations
living at the intersection of animal
human contact
but primarily the democratic republic of
congo or drc
then we have
nate gruber dr nate gruba is an
associate professor of epidemiology of
microbial diseases at the yale school of
public health uh the gruber law lab uses
pathogen genomics and epidemiological
models to investigate the emergence
spread and evolution of viruses such as
zika den dengue
and
sarskov few
and he's done some very interesting work
on the genomic epidemiology of of
several diseases but but more recently
on sars cove too
uh
and um
the the the the frames you see behind
him are our title of the well-deserved
uh uh title pages of journals where um
his uh some of his prominent papers were
published and these are uh sort of well
deserved recognitions of his uh work
uh then we have uh dr akiko wasaki
freshly backed from japan
um she's a sterling professor in more
than one ways in terms of her
professional street cred she is very
strong
her street friend is very sterling
in terms of her scientific contributions
but she's also the named sterling
professor of immunology and molecular
cellular and developmental biology at
yale and an investigator of the howard
hughes medical institute
her research focused uh focuses on the
mechanisms of immune defense against
viruses at the mucosal surfaces
and the development of mucosal vaccine
strategies
she's the co-lead investigator of the
yale covert 19 recovery study which aims
to determine
the changes in immune response of people
with long covid
after vaccination as the director of the
newly formed yale center of infection
and immunity
so
the way we you know those of you who are
used to joining our conversation series
uh the format is similar uh we will have
questions and answers uh and i will be
moderating uh
for
and and i'll start with these questions
uh and then we'll take audience
questions um as we go along so the first
question um and um
you've been working on monkey fox as i
said for a long time and we know that
the disease has been increasing in
recent years in africa not only that it
has been around for a while it has been
increasing
can you talk about the history of the
disease or at least the known history of
the disease and recent trends in africa
absolutely
so saad thanks for organizing this i'm
so thrilled to be here with this
incredible panel uh and so um let me
just tell you a little bit about monkey
pox in general so monkey pox just as a
kind of an encapsulated background about
monkey pox uh monkey pox was first
discovered in in uh non-human primates
in a in a colony
uh in the netherlands where they were
doing polio testing um actually they
were protesting the polio vaccine uh
this was in 1958 and that's why it's
called monkey pox because it was first
discovered in primates uh monkey pox is
actually misnomer it's actually a more
of a rodent pox as we know it although
we we still are trying to to truly
understand what the host range is
the first time that monkey pox was
discovered in humans was in uh 1970 in a
child in the democratic republic of
congo who's nine months old
and this was in the context of smallpox
eradication
so
uh they were doing they were
investigating any case of rash illness
that they were that that could have uh
that could be similar to smallpox
and uh doing virus culture and and
really you know trying to get down to
exactly what what it is
um that's when they discovered that
monkey pox actually could infect humans
uh monkey pox then they they of course
were very concerned about epoxy virus
that was infecting humans and so they
were going to follow it very carefully
um they started doing intensive disease
surveillance in drc and they did find
that there were cases of monkey pox that
were occurring although
because smallpox provides excellent
smallpox vaccine and natural infection
provides excellent immunity to other pox
viruses um which is really the whole
idea of smallpox vaccine anyway i'm sure
you guys all know the history of
smallpox vaccine it's not smallpox it's
uh
cow pox horse pox
uh something we don't really know that
what vaccine of hexa has a whole
different question what vaccine actually
is
um
but um it provides protection against
smallpox so um
the the time that we really understood
most the most about monkey pox was
from
1981 until 1986 so just after smallpox
was eradicated they thought hey we
better really understand about what this
pox virus that's circulating in humans
does so they did intensify disease
surveillance in drc to truly understand
how it was spreading
and they
did this in several health zones so it
wasn't throughout the entire country it
was just in very specific places where
they knew there were cases they found
somewhere around 338 cases they
investigated them carefully
uh and you know that's really what the
base the bulk of monkey pox epidemiology
clinical presentation like this this
work is really predicated on this work
from 1981 to 1986 where they did
intensified disease surveillance they
were giving what's equivalent to like
ninety dollars a person uh for any
report of monkey pox so they were really
doing a lot of case investing you can
imagine 1980s what 90 dollar i mean even
today 90 dollars a lot of money so there
was a lot of incentive people really
knew what to look for at that time so
there was a lot better disease
surveillance ongoing um and that's how
they found these these cases they did a
lot of modeling as a result they did a
lot of ecological studies and what they
determined at that time was that monkey
pox was you know it had limited human to
human spread uh that most cases were
spillover from animals they only were
able to isolate it in a single um single
animal
i think it was a squirrel
in 1984 and by the way it hasn't ever
been um
isolated again except for one other time
in the early 2000s in in a
in an animal in west africa
um but but what they just determined was
that this really wasn't going to be
something that was going to spread and
the reason
and if you look at these early papers
what they say is
something to the effect of this is
paraphrase but because what we're going
to see is increased urbanization we're
going to see improved healthcare we're
going to see you know this was early 80s
right i mean in the early 80s we really
thought um that life was going to be
very very different um there was a very
rosy outlook for what was going to be
happening in all of these places and in
particular in a place like drc so
increased urbanization increased travel
um more reliance on commercial food
products and ag
as opposed to bush meat so therefore we
think that the probability of it
spilling over is going to be less and
less over time but of course a place
like drc that's not what happened what
happened was we had a complete
destruction of the health system there
was a lot prolonged civil war um people
were uh forced into the forests we saw a
lot more um hunting of the forest the
forest became hunted out we're eating a
lot more rodents people uh you know were
malnourished you you saw all of these
comorbidities and so that's really we
saw
in fact so
i along with colleagues in 2010 when we
started our monkey fox projects really
saw this incredible increase in cases it
was totally unexpected and and really
different from what they had predicted
um so
you know that just goes to show you you
always have to be updating your priors
right i mean that's what we do in in
epidemiology is we're always thinking
about
what are our assumptions that we're
making and how are things changing so we
had a change in epidemiologic landscape
we had a change an ecologic landscape
we've seen population explosion over
time we've now seen cases occur in
nigeria as well
and that outbreak has continued over
time
um
and and so you know really where we are
today is that
most of our knowledge is about the this
from the studies that were done in the
80s
i had a study in drc
um knew samurai had a study in drc cdc
how to study these were very limited
scope studies with limited funding
so we have pieces of information but we
really know about it in rural hunting
villages in central africa
the outbreak in 2017 was really a
wake-up call i think to everybody that
monkey pox you know we could be seeing
an ecological change um that the host
range had changed it wasn't recognized
quickly i always draw the example of
um
of west of ebola you know you have
something kind of smoldering around like
in guinea nobody recognizes it all of a
sudden you see it explode
and so what we've now seen
uh our cases just increase um over you
know there was already an outbreak
ongoing by the time they recognized it
we've seen changes in clinical
presentation we've seen all these other
things nigeria is an economic hub and so
as a result we started to see
exportation of cases we had a number of
cases exported that we knew about
of course this could have been happening
for a long time between 2018
to present
and of course that brings us to today
which
um now we have a global outbreak of
monkey pox
yeah so you mentioned that you know
who'd have thought that we'd be talking
about box viruses uh et cetera and it is
for this conversation series that you'd
be interested to know that our last
guess which we thought was the end of
our semester uh uh you know of our
conversation series for the semester
was dr bill feige uh who
devised the strategy to eradicate
smallpox and co-led the program
um etc so to do i i wouldn't have
thought uh even in january that we'd be
talking about tupac's viruses back to
back
um so uh
one thing to remind everyone uh that we
are
you can post your questions in the
question and answer section and we'd be
happy to
after a series of questions that i asked
would be happy to
ask these questions on your behalf uh
from the panel members so nate sort of
the next question is um from you and
ann started uh talking about that
initially
do you think has something changed about
the virus in the way
it is uh spread
uh what can why does genomics tell us
about how it is evolving and spreading
well thanks saad for for the invitation
to join this panel i primarily join so i
can get a front row seat to to hear from
you all and hopefully i i have something
here to contribute
um
so
you know there's there's now about what
a thousand or so um suspected in firm
cases that in in non-endemic countries
and um you know so far with the patterns
and and contact history of the cases
it's supporting human human transmission
that the ann had mentioned that can
occur
um
and but we don't really know yet if
anything is substantially changed about
the virus um especially to the extent
that maybe that it's respiratory borne
um i don't know how much of that is is
actually known and it seems like you
know
primarily right now with a lot of the
cases that is associated with with close
contact um so the genomics can provide
some evidence here to to support some of
those and and allow us to further dig in
um you know first is that most of the
sequence cases um belong to one major
clade
uh that is a part of this uh west
african strain which is thought to be
less virulent um you know and and so far
i guess supporting that is that we
haven't had very many severe cases and
and i don't think any deaths yet
associated at least in the non-endemic
countries is a part of this this um you
know 2022 outbreak um but some has have
hypothesized that there might be virus
adaptations that is associated with
these this clay that may be aiding the
outbreak
um however recently the cdc sequenced uh
some other viruses that are also still
west african played but there are
different lineages sort of within that
and not this main one um so to me that
suggests that there's probably not
something
special about that main clade that is
causing the outbreak it's probably it's
the most common causing human human
transmission
in the endemic regions in in
uh west and uh central africa
um
but you know as as someone who really
likes genomics and likes to nerd out on
some of this stuff uh some of the the
findings have been really interesting so
uh monkey pox virus is this big dna
virus
and it evolves pretty slowly at one to
two mutations per year
because it has these proofreading
mechanisms a lot of the rna viruses that
i study don't have um but there are some
interesting signs of accelerated
evolution that has occurred so this
branch leading up to the major clade of
viruses that have been sequenced has
about 40 mutations that accumulated over
four years it's about 10 times more than
what we thought
um but some terrific sleuthing by
colleagues have pointed out
that a lot of these mutational patterns
actually don't really match the normal
way that viruses mutate which is when
you have when the virus is replicating
it makes some mistakes here and there
and they happen throughout the genome
and some of them are advantageous but
most of them uh don't necessarily help
the virus
these mutations actually look like
patterns that are introduced by the host
immune response these enzymes called
apibacks
that
are known
i think probably most known for their
control of hiv infections and and so
these mutations that have accumulated
might actually be more of scars
on the virus left by the host than true
mutations or signs of adaptation but to
me would it suggest that there's some
extended period of time to human
transmission that has occurred
and and that's what we're seeing with
these cars so it um to me this indicates
that there's probably a much larger
outbreak happening in western central
africa that would than what was realized
and we're seeing the extent of that now
through cases popping up in other
countries
um i would really like to get dr moyne's
take on that to see if she agrees with
me i see her in audience that's helpful
um so with the genomics there's still a
ton on path here we can use it to help
understand if transmission in different
locations if they're connected and to
help us develop hypotheses that we can
both test with clinical studies and with
experimental studies
you know that's interesting and one of
the things is that
there's always the cost for flying blind
um
and
um and it's
in our shared interest
uh to have investments in high quality
epidemiologic and lab surveillance and
the fact
that these investments were not made so
as an example
where was the level of coronavirus
seasonal coronavirus research
before the pandemic
a parallelist flu vaccine and flu virus
research
we we didn't invest in and frankly a lot
of ways the variants are behaving you
know there's an overlap not exactly the
same thing
uh they're
behave behaving in an exaggerated
fashion of seasonal coronaviruses as an
example roughly
stated so we could have learned a lot of
things
from from that similarly if we had had
investments in surveillance and both
epidemiological and lab surveillance
in terms of
coronaviruses or in terms of sorry
monkey parks
we would have been better prepared for
it for the sake of countries where it is
endemic and for other countries that are
facing it now
so so the next question i have is from
akiko
so what do you know what do we know
about the immunology of the monkey parks
virus and how long smallpox vaccine
protection is expected to last uh
what has happened to our population
immunity
uh since the smallpox vaccination
campaigns ended after eradication
yeah thank you sad for the questions and
for having me on this panel too i like
nate i'm sitting here in order to try to
learn from the other experts about what
they have to say and i'd be happy to
come back to this alphabet issue if
there's time later
and no doubt about that too um so yeah
getting back to sad your question um so
punx viruses in general infections in
general induce pretty robust and
long-term immunity against disease
um so smallpox vaccine as an already
described is a live virus related to the
smallpox called vaccinia virus that
normally infects other animals like cows
so while the cdc website says that the
vaccination with the vaccinium virus
provides full immunity to three to five
years
i believe that the data are more
consistent with immunity lasting for a
lot longer
even in those who were only vaccinated
once
so historically the vaccine has been
effective in preventing smallpox in like
95 percent of those who are vaccinated
and against the monkey pox there's about
85 percent protection against the
disease
in addition because fox viruses
replicate slowly the vaccine can be are
proven to be substantially
able to lessen the disease when given
within a few days of exposure
and the correlated protection is well
understood also for the monk for the
smallpox at least
the neutralizing antibody titers above 1
in 32 are associated with protective
immunity against the smallpox disease
and t cells also contribute but
antibodies are sufficient to convert
protection so the routine smallpox
vaccines among the american public
stopped in 1972
after the disease was eradicated in the
u.s
in japan where i grew up the public
vaccination against smallpox also ended
in 1976
and consequently i only received one
dose of the vaccine
but in the study published in 2008
the researchers found that in 97 of the
participants that they've investigated
there is no decrease in vaccinia
specific antibody titers
that were noted with age over a
follow-up period of 88 years
that's pretty remarkable
another study found that t cell
responses after vaccinia vaccine lasts
for 30 years
so we can expect significant level
protection against disease in those who
have been previously vaccinated with the
vaccinia vaccine
and hopefully the same kind of
protection would apply for monkey pox
so a related um sort of question and
actually i'll take a question from the
audience because it's related
sort of kind of
earlier than we planned to so this
question is from edward nirenberg
um is there any heterologous and this is
to you akiko
um do you think and are you aware of any
heterologous protection against monkey
box virus from molluscum contagiosum
virus um
you know
you know any thoughts on that look early
in the outbreak we should be asking
broad questions
uh because um and then sort of exploring
these kind of hypotheses obviously this
is not purely early in the outbreak but
in this phase of the outbreak
yeah so i i have no data about that but
um really it depends on how related
these viruses are in and if you have any
insights please jump in
well i think that so i think that this
is a really interesting question i don't
know about molluscum contagiosum i i
don't know and that's a good question i
literally was just writing it down
saying i think that's an interesting
question mark zlifka might be a good
person to ask about this because he's
the person who in 2008 i believe was his
paper you were talking about he did some
of that early work
but you know it what it made me think
about and these are just thoughts that
i'm having you know and this is all part
of the scientific process right this is
why it's so great that you guys are
getting all of us together to start
talking about these things because this
is how science is done and these kind of
questions come up so when you were
talking about this and thinking okay
well you know t-cell responses last for
about 30 years we have long-term
protection you know i had a paper in
pnas in 2010 where i demonstrated this
long-term rise um in or this this
extensive rise in cases of monkeypox
since the 1980s
and really correlated it with the
cessation of vaccination um and we
really had almost no cases and
individuals who
had been vaccinated at that at that
point
but what it makes me think about in
general is what is the threshold
at which we really start to see this and
and will we need and i'm just these are
these are just questions that come into
my head you know if if we think that
there's like a certain threshold of
immunity that we need to maintain to be
able to
avoid this i mean of course what you
really want to do is you want to be able
to do that in places where monkey box is
endemic right now because it's always
better to control it at the source this
goes back to what saad was saying at the
very beginning which is you know we pay
the price every single time that we
don't invest in disease surveillance lab
surveillance and this kind of
infrastructure and as my late
father-in-law always used to say it's
much easier to stay out of trouble than
it is to have to get out of trouble
um and and i really think that that's
you know it just couldn't be more true
in than in public health
um i mean that's that's really the point
but i just start to wonder well what is
that threshold and maybe we'll have to
you know
reach that threshold again either by
natural or preferably vaccine induced
immunity by re-vaccinating a certain you
know certain groups to be able to um
really achieve that threshold again in
particular
if we start to see this virus establish
itself in hume as you know as something
that is spreading even at a low level
amongst humans
or my big concern is if we see a spill
back or reverse zoonosis
um
you know then then we're really going to
have to consider what does it take to be
able to keep fox viruses at bay and it
then goes back to what nathan was
talking about which is you know what
what do we think about these genetic
changes and what does this what does
this mean
um you know pox viruses are stable
viruses we don't see a lot of
um
we
really don't see the kind of of
potential
for adaptation and fitness that we do
for example in a coronavirus
that said we do see changes do we know
what they mean what will they mean we
you know these are things we need to get
in front of as opposed to chasing behind
them
yeah so um
i have i also have a i was born outside
the u.s i have a small box car
uh because you know
a lot of parts of the world
that vaccination
um
was stopped
a bit later but we should remember look
uh these countries where even
you know vaccination was stopped later
have really really young populations
and so according to some estimates even
if under the best case scenario
the population immunity provided
by a smallpox vaccine is around a
quarter of the population uh because of
the pop just the population pyramid and
even and and the the fact that um with
smallpox uh only or not only 85
protection is high
uh so even if that kind of a scenario so
we should keep in mind it's not just the
immunity part but also the demography
um in in some of those uh countries
so um coming back to uh to nate what
convent
what can we do actually you know what
i'll i'll start with you again uh and um
what do we
how should we respond to the monkey box
outbreak uh or these sets of outbreaks
uh including uh what can we learn from
our african colleagues who have been
dealing this for many years and by the
way it said we extended an invitation
and there were some initial interests
from our colleagues uh from africa cdc
but you know for for various reasons
logistical reasons they couldn't join us
uh for for this panel uh but but what
can we learn uh from the previous
experience in terms of
addressing
this infection in these outbreaks
and apply that to this series of
outbreaks so i use the term outbreak and
outbreaks interchangeably i do think
it's a set of outbreaks uh that are
happening
that may have overlapping factors uh
that you know that has made this moment
where this is happening but i think we
may
find out that these are independent
uh but concurrent outbreaks
well i think that that what you're
saying is is right i mean we're seeing
um
a series of global outbreaks and i think
this goes back to you know
that we're clearly seeing rises in cases
in
in africa in the traditionally endemic
zone
and it's likely seated outbreaks that we
just haven't been paying attention to
and in particular because the west
african clade tends to have a more mild
presentation all things being relative
and could be mistaken for other things
um
and uh i think that
it's one of these things if you're you
know staring into the dark you might not
see anything you've got to turn the
light or shine a flashlight you're going
to catch something but if you turn all
the lights on you're going to see a lot
more and i really think that this is
about situational awareness we i i
believe
that the um that's
that some of these cases that we've seen
um in the u.s are actually related
more closely related genetically to the
outbreak in
or the the case
in texas right so that suggests that
there probably been multiple
introductions and now that we're looking
for it we're actually seeing it and this
could have been something that's been
spreading for a while even at a very low
level but then finally reached a network
where it could propagate very quickly
and and now we're seeing all these cases
so so your question i think really is so
what now what do we do now how
here we are what do we do and i think
that there are a number of things we
need to do i mean first of all we need
to be able to have this kind of
situational awareness so what do you do
you need good
syndromic surveillance you need good um
clinical
pictures and and information so that
clinicians can actually make these
diagnoses so that people can can
identify themselves as potent at
particular risk you need good risk
communication
um so that everybody understands what
the risks are
what how this is all you know
potentially going to impact them
of course beyond the clinical part you
need diagnostic capacity
and and right now we're very hampered by
this diagnostic capacity you know i i
just saw
a note that that there are several cases
i think 10 cases of orthodox positive
orthodox positive cases in new york
right now so now they're going to have
to send them on for confirmation for
monkey pox and so this is a process you
know listen at least we have orthodox
assays that are out there and so we
don't you know that in and of itself
you know i think is is going to be
relevant then you can send it on for
further but we really are going to have
to expand
our our diagnostic capacity at a at a
local level
um at a national level we're going to
have to make this something that's
that's very accessible if we really want
to be able to capture the cases and you
know this is just standard public health
you're going to need you know ideally
you'd want to have things like lateral
flow assays and rapid or point of care
diagnostics but even you know in the
interim really rapidly scaling this up
will be important you know syndromic
surveillance communication
um to everybody and then we have to have
a really clear plan about prioritizing
vaccines and therapeutics and who's
going to need them how they work for
people
what the plan is going to be to do this
and that really means that we need to to
be scaling that up as well
now at the same time we have to really
be scaling up all of our research um
you know to be able to truly understand
what's going on we have to be able to
characterize transmission mechanisms and
its potential we need to cl characterize
clinical presentation and disease
severity and various risk groups
um you know we need to know what the
virus does in in immunocompromised
individuals we need to know is there an
asymptomatic form of infection do
asymptomatic people transmit i mean we
we've we've done this dance before we
know all the things we don't know and i
think the most important thing is to be
humble about what we know what we don't
know because what we know is really
about how this virus has been spreading
traditionally in a in a very different
epidemiologic and ecological landscape
so i think that the key is
you know saying okay well here's what we
know so far
now we need to go further so that we
truly do understand that so we can get
in front of it because stakes are
frankly very high
you know if this virus becomes as i said
before if it becomes established even at
a very low level in human populations or
we see reverse spillover you know we're
really going to have to
reconsider
um
how we view a circulating ortho pox
virus in humans and do we think that
this is enough of a risk that we're
going to have to really reconsider what
vaccination means
um and that was one of the big benefits
of smallpox eradication program right
you eradicate virus you're able to you
know prevent the human suffering which
is the key
issue but then you're also able to
dedicate those resources for
manufacturer vaccines and distribution
of vaccines to other virus or other
other pathogens to other issues
and and so you know it's an enormous
step backwards for public health to have
to really reconsider
utilization of smallpox vaccine again um
you know in public health so the stakes
are are quite high i think
you're you're muted yeah so um you're
absolutely right and that brings me to
to nate what can we do to prepare for a
local cluster if it happens uh what
research questions do you plan to
address i know in on you know in your in
an ideal world you you would still be we
wouldn't have had a pandemic we wouldn't
have had a monkey box outbreak and you'd
be working on dengue
um
but
but you know we all know uh that this
will require a scientific response and
so so what do you think what should we
do with the local cluster and what what
questions we should ask especially what
you think you know what what you are
planning to ask yeah so
um first i want to start by just
reiterating some points from ann that i
think are incredibly important here is
that
we first need a better handle on the
extent of local transmission if it's
happening right like in our communities
it it it's really feels like we're
getting like the tip of the iceberg here
and i'm not saying it's a it's a cobit
situation where there's like you know
gonna have
hundreds of thousands of people being
infected in just a short amount of time
but
it's it's likely a lot more than what we
know
and um and this absolutely needs to
include the rollout of frontline
diagnostics
so currently the the testing is still
encompassed in the cdc's uh laboratory
response network
um so this includes more than 60 labs
across all 50 u.s states and and most of
these are
located in state facilities
so if you were to you know present to
the ed or your clinician with with
monkey pox like symptoms what they would
do is they would take a swab of the pox
or lesion and they would first send it
to the
state labs for this broad
um you know family level test
and then if it's positive there then the
samples are sent to the cdc for
confirmation they do a genotyping assay
and determine if it's you know the west
african strain as the as they have been
doing and then they do sequencing and
this is the similar sort of setup that
was that we had at the beginning of
starscope 2 in early 2020.
this system works great for rare
pathogens because hospitals and
diagnostic labs cannot reasonably be
expected to have tests for every single
pathogen that is out there right this is
why the laboratory response network
exists so that when we have something
strange that comes up we can figure out
what it is and the cdc can respond
around that
however given that monkey pox is here
like we know that it's here there are
cases that are rising they're rising
around the country and around the world
it's my opinion that we really need to
roll out these front line tests and to
be able to reduce both the resulting
times of having tests to go from sent to
a lab and then sent to another lab and
also to increase testing capacity but
maybe even more importantly it might
make ordering these tests easier
especially in the circumstances when the
symptoms resemble so many other common
diseases we're hearing of a lot of cases
in msm communities where the symptoms
look like other stis there might be just
one or two pox that are located on or
near the genitals and
if if you know someone is not astute one
it could be missed but also just could
think it might be something else and we
almost need to include that right now in
general sti testing and that can't
necessarily happen i think in the
current system that we have
um
but it's not really clear to me what the
frontline
labs would actually use because there's
and i don't know of any commercially
available monkey pox test that is
approved by the fda that we could just
put in all these laps
that is a problem
so um my group's first goal just kind of
how we did i feel like deja vu a bit i
know this is not covet but there are
some things that are related to this and
at the beginning of the covet pandemic
our initial response was like how do we
help diagnostics in any way possible so
what we are doing is that we are just
working with several different pcr tests
to optimize the different conditions
to do comparisons to
allow different um diagnostic labs to be
able to look at results select what
tests they want to do for internal
validation
um until we actually
have some commercial uh
options available
relatedly we're also working to
streamline the sequencing assays
essentially our goal is to take covet
seek right all this 11 million sequences
that have been generated for source code
v2 sequencing and adapt monkeypox virus
sequencing to fit in those systems
because we know labs know how to do it
there's a lot of capacity that's built
up and we need to be able to validate
that so we can have along with the
diagnostics we can have the sequencing
because we know how important the
sequencing is now i think
um and then finally if i have a local
cluster
right it's it's our plan to conduct
clinical studies to determine first like
when and where do you find the virus in
various parts of the body different
tissues
um you know sample types and everything
and and both this could help improve
diagnostics right if we could if for
example if there's asymptomatic
transmission that is happening
if the primary form of being able to
test for monkey pox virus is via a
lesion or a pox on the skin and if you
don't have one how do we test for it
right if if we can detect this in oral
fluids or saliva and if that could be a
great test that would be fantastic we
would like to be able to know that so we
could roll something like that out
and also i think that this would help
shed light on transmission if we don't
necessarily know how it's happening if
there are cases where transmission is
happening where it's not very intimate
close you know skin to skin contact
right we need to be able to use that so
we can implement the public health uh
practices um that we know that can then
stop transmission
yeah
so the only way i know of controlling an
outbreak is to get ahead of it and we
are still following this these series of
outbreaks as long as you're behind an
outbreak
you have a little chance of controlling
it but but again just to question
everyone that this is now we're not
looking at uh the start of another uh
covert 19 pandemic but things can be
significantly impactful even without um
getting to that level i hope that
doesn't become our only benchmark of
paying attention to to these kinds of
diseases um akiko you know
obviously
like
any
disaster movie included in an outbreak
vaccines are the heroes
and the the narrative arc ends that with
an effective vaccine we know in real
life the story is a little bit more
complicated
uh what do you think about the pipeline
for monkey pox the vaccine pipeline for
monkey pox um and any any thoughts on
that
yeah
absolutely so i'm glad that the
immunology is the hero
in most of these situations well i would
say more broadly vaccinology as a
vaccinologist
i think uh you know immunology is part
of that family of disciplines
absolutely so yeah um the good news is
that there are vaccines that are
effective as i already discussed
against the monkey pox and there is one
that is currently fda approved
called genealos it's also known as inva
nex which is a replication defective of
a vaccine that's given subcutaneously
and it's a live vaccine produced from
the strain called modified vaccinia
ankara and it's like i said it's an
attenuated and non-replicating
virus that can a vaccine that can be
given to people and that is already fda
approved
to prevent monkeypox disease
but the strategic national stockpile has
other smallpox vaccines that could also
be deployed if needed
such as the more traditional
vaccinia virus vaccine called aca m2000
it's also known as
and it's a live vaccinia vaccine that's
given percutaneously
that's sort of the
closely related to the original
vaccine that was used in the 70s
but this one is uh produced in a
laboratory setting in tissue culture
purified vaccinia virus that's been
given to people for prevention of
smallpox
disease and i think could be applicable
to monkey pox disease as well
and there's one more
vaccine that is in the stockpile
which is the aventis faster smallpox
vaccine
which is still an investigational
vaccine but that can be used under
emergency um use authorization so there
are these vaccines that are known to
work against small box that could be um
used for monkey pox um and as i said
there's only there's only already one
that's fda approved for the monkey pox
um and then i know that
other companies like moderna are already
working on
developing a monkey box vaccine so
hopefully there'll be a plenty of
different
vaccines in the pipeline that can combat
the disease if needed
so so having been involved in the early
2000s uh in some sort of planning around
a possible smallpox by a terrorist
attack there was a lot of discussion of
that
um you know after 9 11
and
i had the privilege of being involved
with some vaccine policy related
especially safety
one of our initial thinking was
that people like me who have small box
cars um
could be on the front line uh of the
response because
of
that kind of immunity and here obviously
cross protection against monkeybox as
you alluded to that we have evidence of
that but we need to do updated studies
do you think that could be a part of
strategies that people you know one part
of uh diversity in this country is that
they're people who are older who have
had a smallpox vaccine and people who
are relatively younger because they are
immigrants have received a smallpox
vaccine and this is true for the rest of
the country as well do you think there
is a value in doing those kind of
studies of uh you know the residual
or or ongoing
protect cross protection to make sure
that we have a sort of a more
comprehensive public health response
every where we leverage that diversity
yeah i think that is really an important
um issue especially for those who may be
coming in close contact with patients
with the monkey pox
infection and um even though i said that
you know pox viruses are provide robust
lifelong lifelong immunity this is just
um an assumption against the monkey pox
right now so we do need to do much
better sort of zero surveillance and if
possible t cell assays uh to see like
how long does the immunity lasted like
against the monkey box and whether we
need a booster and of course a booster
is always a great thing to do if there's
sufficient vaccine available but as
unalluded to the the primary like you
know the most urgent target population
maybe the the people who are living in
the endemic area um so so you know again
how do we distribute the vaccine dose in
a in a proper and equitable manner to
control this pandemic that's sort of
yeah an important question going forward
right i'm going to sort of frame a
question
um from elizabeth tuckwell
who posed that question i think the
intention is to clarify something i know
the answer to that but i think
we
should address that question head-on
early
on which is is there any lab that might
have enhanced monkey pox such as some
speculated for
covet i think
we should address that head-on so that
there isn't an information gap uh where
a lot of conspiracies then evolve nate
i'll put you on the spot for that
i so i i don't think there's any
evidence for that i mean and
there's really as as anna had mentioned
too there's not really a lot of labs
that are even working on monkey pox for
for this um to happen but i
there's
nothing that concerning that
any sort of red flags that i have seen
um that would take me down this route
but you know of course
there's there's it and also
specifically here with with the viruses
from this outbreak we we have a a recent
common ancestor from the outbreak in
nigeria in 2017
um in the evolutionary patterns that
we've seen since then makes sense
biologically with human human
transmission um so if there was any
engineering it wouldn't even be clear
what that would be that would have aided
anything here so um
i think that would be a very remote
possibility
yeah and then the other thing is that
base just the probability of of the fact
um you know because there is a natural
you know the natural transmission is
happening for a while in a pretty
substantial endemic
area
so so again if you if you look at the
that kind of a counterfactual it is more
likely much more likely uh for for it to
have come from a quote-unquote natural
source
uh at this point
i want to just uh yeah go ahead please
remember a little bit because i mean
listen we've all been i mean if you look
back at even the papers that we wrote
back in 2010 not just me i mean our
colleagues at the cdc
you know all all of us were saying
listen you gotta you've gotta be able to
control monkey pox now
and really understand it because if we
see cases continue to rise as we predict
they will
we're eventually going to see
importations
and and and that's just i mean this this
isn't
a mysterious virus
that that we you know that we hadn't
identified before this is a this is a
known pathogen
um you know it that that did exactly
what we predicted
it could potentially do which is if it
happened to get itself into an
appropriate network
an advantageous network that it would be
able to to spread rapidly and that's
what we're seeing now of course we have
all of these you know concerns okay well
what happens if it started getting into
immunocompromised populations could we
see it mutate more if we see
you know this kind of you know ability
to to continue to spread i mean we're
gonna we're gonna get given this virus
some some runway that it hasn't had
before
but this isn't a novel pathogen that
we've never seen before and it's doing
exactly what we
expect it would do
having gotten into the networks that
it's gotten into i mean there's it just
the clinical presentation is a little
bit
different than we had been paying
attention to but it turns out there have
been records of this in in niger i mean
reports of this in nigeria that just
nobody had the funds or the ability to
do kind of research to be able to
document this where it was already
happening now we're seeing it happen you
know on a much larger global
scale and i'm sure our african
colleagues would say hey you know we've
been seeing this for a while if you've
invested in our networks and our ability
to to control this in a place where it
is endemic and we'd already know about
this we already know what the risks are
and we just haven't
done that we
we've
you know ignored that possibility and of
course you know this is a situation
where
you know we we we've come into this you
know i i keep liking this is the same as
always i that my analogy for this is
like we've tuned into a new tv series
and we don't know what episode we've
landed on is it two is it five is it ten
are we in season three you know where
are we i don't know i mean we definitely
missed some of the origin story here but
the early origin story we've got like we
know how monkey pox where monkey parks
came from we know
um that this was always a possibility it
was just low on the list priorities of
something to be able to pay attention to
and even we knew there was this
existential threat that this could
possibly happen i mean it's always like
the you know the squeaky wheel gets the
grease and monkey pox was not squeaky
enough
to get that that kind of grease
um
and and now we are here in a situation
where we've given this virus a you know
an opportunity to
to spread it spreads well with close
contact and
um fomites and
respiratory droplets you know at the
minimum those are things we know and we
you know hey like what could be
better than sexual networks for that
that just
it just makes sense you know i i think
at the end of the day
so i know so so i can actually i i think
the liberty to put you on the spot and
in terms of because we have a lot of
people who are early stage investigators
and students who um
who attend these events so tell me a
little bit about your experience uh with
getting resources from monkeybox and
how and your case studies to my mind
is a microcosm of how governments
and international entities should invest
better in this kind of work because uk
award
which is a primary investigator early
stage investigator award was on monkey
parks uh so so you know
would you
care to elaborate a little bit on what
you had to face
sure so you know i came to this from our
our common ancestor are our common
advisor mark steinhoff at hopkins um and
i went to nih actually so i was at um
the uh the center at nichd
and i was a program officer on a project
in drc
and um when i was there i recognized
that there were cases of monkey pucks
there because i'd worked in disease
eradication as peace corps volunteer and
then i worked in polio eradication i
worked with mark on pediatric infectious
diseases vaccine preventable diseases
you know i was really attuned to this
issue of vaccine preventable diseases
and when i met with my now very
long-term collaborators and close
friends jean-jacques moyembe and also
the late emil okitalanda the dean of the
kinshasa school public health director
of national lab
they they mentioned that there were all
these cases of monkey pox that weren't
being reported and i thought that this
was really important and interesting but
at the time you know there really wasn't
a mechanism to be able to send them to
get tested and the congo didn't have
that ability
so we sent them to
the you know just using
um i i don't like we scrounge around for
some funds and we're able to send them
to
germany
for the pox coordinating lab that was
able to do these analyses and we were
able it was our first paper there was an
eid just really demonstrating that we
were seeing increasing cases of monkey
box so we were able then to leverage
that to get a grant it was you know was
at the time was a you know a sizable
grant to be able to look at
the increase in cases of monkey pox and
so we set up enhanced disease
surveillance and some of the early sites
i mean it wasn't perfect we did the best
we could we did some cereal surveys and
we really found this increasing rise in
cases meanwhile i got my k on monkey pox
epidemiology of monkey pox and when i
finished you know in order to be able to
continue this work i was gonna need more
than half a million dollars for five
years to to do this kind of work to be
able to do the epidemiology work to be
able to support the infrastructure in
drc to be able to do that kind of
intensified disease surveillance to be
able to do the kind of
um molecular epidemiology that needed to
be done to be able to have that that lag
capacity and that's live far beyond that
and so i really
you know
wasn't going to be able to sustain that
as a junior investigator writing my
first ro1 afterwards on on that and
because i you know i didn't have
all of this infrastructure that i was
plugging into this is really
infrastructure that i developed on my
own it just it just seemed overwhelming
and impossible to to do
and so you know we we kind of pivoted to
other things for a while and we've
always been working for a low level on
monkey pox working on the data
publishing our results can you know we
have little projects here and there to
be able to continue to do active
surveillance for for several years
um and it was only a couple years ago
that we were able to get um funding to
to do
you know real um
uh
you know to be able to get back on the
ground and really do
um
a more
robust project on on monkey pox again
um
just you know the last couple years and
that was because there was an outbreak
in nigeria right so all of a sudden
there was some renewed interest that we
saw this this shift this you know
explosion of cases there and so all of a
sudden it was clear that this was
something that needed to be paid
attention to
at some level but you know it's really
hard to do this kind of work in
low resource settings and to be able to
do the kind of enhanced disease
surveillance that needs to happen i mean
you know governments can't pay for that
the you know i've heard from colleagues
in nigeria you know many quotes to them
saying you know listen we knew that
there are a lot of cases out here we
couldn't do anything about it in drc
it's the same thing i mean they don't
have the resources what they're able to
do is case counting but they can't look
at transmission they can't do case
investigations it can't do all the kind
of things that need to be done i mean
these this is it's very expensive
um very
consuming work and you know drc has been
very consumed with a lot of other
um very serious outbreaks to contend
with including you know back-to-back
ebola outbreaks and other things that
have really you know i i have to i
really have to give
credit to my congolese colleagues who
are just heroes who have worked
themselves to the bone i mean you know i
i see this burnout and and
and how tired people are from from covid
well just imagine with these incredible
people working you know with with many
fewer doctors many fewer researchers
many
fewer resources just doing incredible
work on the ground with with limited
resources and combating multiple
outbreaks all at the same time with very
little funding and very little resource
so i mean i i think that this just goes
back to
you know you pay now or you pay later
and um
you got to pick what price you're
willing to pay and when you're going to
pay it and we've often said oh we'll pay
on the back end as opposed to paying
upfront um and you know that that costs
us dearly in so many ways
so one last question and just if we are
sort of uh before i wrap up
um
and a quick question but there's you
know several people are asking the same
question in different ways
uh in our question and answer box which
is and akiko i'll ask you this question
should the general public get vaccinated
again you know with a smallpox vaccine
presumably or a smallpox an mba vaccine
tested against uh munchpaks but but
generally speaking should the general
public think about getting vaccinated
well at this point in the pandemic i
don't think that's quite nice
i know that it was uh i'm sorry at this
point
at this point of the infections
that's going on i don't think the
general public needs to be vaccinated of
course uh you know we can never
underestimate the viruses right there
may be future variants that uh even
though it's unlikely could be more
transmissible or whatever and which
point we do need to reconsider these
kinds of um equations but
i think you know it's not at the point
where we have to worry about the general
spreading of the virus everywhere um but
we do need to really keep an eye and
potentially vaccinate the people around
the um sort of uh transmission sites and
and ring vaccination and other strategy
that make more sense to contain the the
spread of virus throughout the world i
think that that's a better approach than
doing
general vaccination
so a couple of things as i wrap up so i
do believe there should be we should
build a button but not press it i do
believe that we need to make investments
and prepare
even with large groups not you know
falling even if you fall
uh far short of a general everyone
getting vaccinated program and if you
have a large uh
set of high-risk groups
et cetera even that's a substantial
investment so we should do that
absolutely now
but also we should prepare for a few
other things first of all because it is
the initial clusters are identified in
msm communities
we need to get ahead of any potential
stigma
we can't
you know just repeat disease after
disease where
based on ethnicity or sexual preference
because remember a lot of these things
are identified in certain sexual
networks but they're not it's not the
virus it's the initial identification
that is happening so we don't know so
there may be certain risk factors
associated with different kind of
contact but
but we need to address stigma because
it's in all our interests that we
get ahead of this virus by through
collaboration of
incorporation of various communities
and it is a moral responsibility to
address it where you know where it is
impacting the other thing is we need to
get ahead of misinformation um and we
need to uh do that and and we need to
have a robust research agenda
and uh i we received our group received
the first irb approval of our first
study
on this series of outbreaks uh two days
ago and so we already in the field
uh et cetera not in the field uh in drc
etc but it's a different kind of study
but so we'll have to have this robust
agenda with that i'll wrap up with only
50 minutes 50 seconds over our time i'll
wrap up stay tuned for our fall season
of the conversation series um and um and
likely um to have and we know that
the speakers we are lining up
will attract a lot of interest so look
forward to that and and just repeat
akiko did not mean to say pandemic
at this point and but things can be
highly disruptive even
before uh you know without being a
full-on pandemic with that thank you um
and thanks for joining us
and and obviously i couldn't get to uh
all the questions and they were really
nice questions i wish i had the time
thank you thank you
thank you